[Music]  Nicole Kidman is one hot mama fantastic  I love it the 50 year old actress and  mom sizzles on the cover of love  magazine in a sexy red swimsuit here's  Nicole looking showdown ready in  form-fitting swimwear and a cowgirl hat  while walking down the street for her  photo shoot the mags quoted the big  little live star in the Instagram  caption writing I thought about this  shoot afterwards I was like what was I  doing I lost my mind  how are the shots do they look crazy Wow  a big wow well we have a feeling her  husband country singer Keith Urban would  be proud of this cowgirl chic look but  Keith has told ET he really loves  watching his wife master motherhood  right of a mom loving maternal and  teaching me a lot about how to raise  children especially girls I have no  reference for girls that grew up in a  house of boys it's quite quite the  learning curve  [Music]  you